grosse frayeur en Isère ou un élève a
crié Allahu Akbar en plein cours avant
de menacer de commettre un attentat ça
s'est passé ce vendredi 29 septembre au
lycée professionnel Galilée de Vienne un
élève de 16 ans s'est levé en plein
cours et a crié Allahu Akbar après avoir
regardé une vidéo du groupe djihadiste
état islamique sur son ordinateur il
aurait ensuite menacé le proviseur de
commettre en attentat s'il était exclu
de l'établissement selon la procureur de
la République de Vienne Audrey le jeune
de 16 ans déjà condamné à deux reprises
est déjà suivi par le juge des enfants
de Vienne dans le cadre de deux dossiers
récents l'un pour vol par effraction en
mai 2023 et l'autre pour infraction à la
législation sur les stupéfiants en mars
2023 le suspect a effectué 48 heures de
garde à vue au cours desquelles une
expertise psychiatrique a été réalisée
et des investigations sont en cours pour
mieux cerner le profil de ce mineur qui
sera jugé le 16 octobre pour apologie du
terrorisme et menace de commettre un
crime cet événement survient alors que
plusieurs lycées en France ont été la
cible de menace d'attentatrice très au
sérieux mi-septembre le lycée Paul
Eluard à Saint-Denis avaient notamment
reçu un mail dans lequel l'auteur
indiqué avoir posé une bombe dans
l'établissement et qu'il viendra
exterminer tous les coups phares avec sa
kalachnikov en provenance du Yémen plus
largement le 20 septembre dernier c'est
Gérald Darmanin qui avait mis en garde
contre un risque terroriste très
prégnant après des menaces proférées par
Al-Qaïda contre la France et la Suède
dans un magazine de propagande